y el empleo en América Latina según este
reporte apenas crecerá un cero coma
nueve por ciento pero la tasa de
desempleo se mantendrá estable Qué
significa esto para las regiones del
mundo que tiene una población joven y en
edad productiva cómo sería nuestro año
Bueno lo que significa fundamentalmente
América Latina no solamente se está
empobreciendo sino que está perdiendo
muchos pasos con respecto al crecimiento
global porque lo que muestra
fundamentalmente es que el riesgo de una
década perdida en América Latina es
enorme no solamente es un problema de
una recuperación después del covid-19
muy pobre sino es que ya antes del covid
19 América Latina estaba mostrando unas
señales muy preocupantes de altísima
inflación por la impresión constante de
moneda por parte de algunos países y
segundo
crecimiento mucho más bajo de lo que
sería el potencial de una región que es
indudablemente una región con un enorme
potencial económico
mire y además Daniel preocupa que una
tendencia que se va a mantener es la de
la desigualdad de género el año pasado
la población activa masculina en América
Latina fue del 70% y la femenina apenas
del 46,5% porque seguimos incapaces de
superar una amplia brecha de género y
cómo nos afecta a las mujeres
no claramente Hay un problema de
constantes trabas a la inversión y
además Hay un problema cultural de
la idea generalizada de que las tareas
domésticas tienen que recaer en las
mujeres es algo que se ha superado en
muchísimas economías en muchos países
pero en muchos países de latinoamérica
Todavía queda una un pozo cultural
equivocado en ese sentido yo creo que
cómo se soluciona todo esto esto como no
se soluciona es como se ha intentado
hacer en los últimos años en Argentina o
en otros países de con unas enormes
políticas de intervención lo que se
necesita de verdad en América Latina es
mucha mayor inversión mucho mayor
capital del resto del mundo que permita
que ese avance que ha sido espectacular
hay que reconocer también en los últimos
50 años
no solamente
continúe avanzando sino que llegue a las
cotas de igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres eh que existen en otros países
que incluso Pues están en niveles de
desarrollo pues similares Incluso un
poco más bajos que los de muchos países
de América Latina bien y muy rápidamente
Le quiero preguntar cómo nos va a seguir
afectando este año la Guerra de Ucrania
yo creo que la Guerra de Ucrania ya ha
dejado de tener el impacto de ruptura de
acceso a bienes y servicios y de enormes
precios de las materias primas yo creo
que esos son esos importantes Porque la
realidad es que el precio del trigo y el
precio del petróleo el gas natural se
han dado la vuelta a lo largo del año
2022 y eso está reduciendo la presión
inflacionaria pero la Guerra de Ucrania
sigue siendo un gran problema
geopolítico y en eso afecta al corazón
de América Latina porque hay muchísimos
países que están muy alineados con una
parte del conflicto y de la invasión de
Ucrania es con Rusia y con lo que
podríamos Llamar los aliados de Rusia y
hay otra parte que está muy alineada con
el pueblo ucraniano con la y con los
países que apoyan a Ucrania verdad